هَيَّا تَعَالَى لأُسْرَتِنَا  حَتَّى تَكْمُلَ فَرْحَتُنَا
تَلْعَبُ مَعَنَا كَيْ نَفْرَحْ تَجْرِىْ بِالبَيْتِ وتَمْرَحْ
تُضْحِكُنَا لَمَّا تَمْزَحْ  هَيَّا اخْرُجْ كَيْ تُسْعِدُنَا
هَيَّا هيا هيا  هَيَّا تَعَالَى لأُسْرَتِنَا
لاَ لَنْ أَخْرُجْ قَدْ أُزْعِجُكُمْ  إنِي أَبَدًا لاَ أَفْهَمُكُمْ
لَو أَبْكِى واااء واااء هَذي طريقتي لأُكَلِّمَكُمْ
مَاذَا يَحْدُثْ ..مَا أغْضَبَكَ  مَاذَا عِنْدَكْ هَيَّا احْكِيهْ
اخْبِرْنَا مَا أَزْعَجَكَ  فَهِّمْنَا حَتَّى نُنْهِيهْ
أُخْتِي قَالَتْ أَخَذَ مَكَانِي  وتَضَايَقَ مِنِّى إِخْوَانِي
أَحْتَاجُ لِعَوْنٍ وَمَحَبَّةْ  فَصَغِيرٌ كَفِّى وعُيُونِي
أُمِّي أَيْضًا مِنِّي تَتْعَبْ  وأَبِي يَصْرُخُ لَمَّا نَلْعَبْ
أُمِّي تَكْنُسُ تَمْسَحُ َتْطْبُخْ  والبِيْتُ جَمِيلٌ ومُرَتَّبْ
مَاذَا يَحْدُثُ لَوْ فَهِمُوا  نَحْتَاجُ مَكَانًا نَلْعَبْ
بِبَسَاطَةْ هَيَّا ابْتَسِمُوا لَو نَتَقَلَّبْ نَتَشَقْلَبْ
هَلْ أَنَا غَلْطَانْ طبعا لاَ  بل أنا زعلان ولَكَ الحَقْ
هَيَّا تَعَالَى لأُسْرَتِنَا  حَتَّى تَكْمُلَ فَرْحَتُنَا
تَلْعَبُ مَعَنَا كَيْ نَفْرَحْ تَجْرِىْ بِالبَيْتِ وتَمْرَحْ
تُضْحِكُنَا لَمَّا تَمْزَحْ  هَيَّا اخْرُجْ كَيْ تُسْعِدُنَا
هَيَّا هيا هيا  هَيَّا تَعَالَى لأُسْرَتِنَا
ماما قَالَتْ سَأُسَمِيهْ  عَلَى اسْمِ أبِى وأُرَبِّيهْ
كَي يُصْبِحَ يَومًا مِثْلَهْ  قَامَةْ والكُلُّ يُحَيِّيِهْ
يَصْرخُ بَابَا هَذَا ابْنِى  وسَيُكْتَبُ جَانِبَ إسْمِي
والحَقُّ مَعِي لأُسَمِّيهْ  عَلَى أَبَتِي مَنْ يَمْنَعُنِي
ماذا يحدث لو هَدَأُوا بِمَوَدَّتِهِمْ واتَّفَقُوا
بَدَلَ خِصَامٍ وشِجَارٍ  أَبْعَدَهُمْ لَمَّا انْفَعَلُوا
هَلْ أَنَا غَلْطَانْ طبعا لاَ  بل أنا زعلان ولَكَ الحَقْ
هَيَّا تَعَالَى لأُسْرَتِنَا  حَتَّى تَكْمُلَ فَرْحَتُنَا
تَلْعَبُ مَعَنَا كَيْ نَفْرَحْ تَجْرِىْ بِالبَيْتِ وتَمْرَحْ
تُضْحِكُنَا لَمَّا تَمْزَحْ  هَيَّا اخْرُجْ كَيْ تُسْعِدُنَا
هَيَّا هيا هيا  هَيَّا تَعَالَى لأُسْرَتِنَا